welcome to mobile electronic diagnostic
best car fixes today please subscribe
share and like
today we have 2007.
how you know it's 7 or 6. just come here
down for all nissan infinity look at the
left side corner
and here zero three zero seven that
means two thousand seven
and infinity is actually is nissan
manufactured by nissan
but is a different name for quality car
it is actually a quality car
okay you have like four players for seat
adjustment
seat memory this is a quality car now
we need to program a key as usual
i give my recommendation to all auto
repair shop
to have this machine because it's a
diagnostic tools
and at the same time can do a lot of
functions
for configuration of computers and
a lot of service that you can you can do
it with this one
without taking the car to the dealer
it it is a bridge between immobilizer
system
program service and diagnosis
right now i'm gonna put the hazard on
okay i'm gonna put the battery
i'm gonna put the battery on first
because the battery is dead this car is
parked for a long time
this is the key we have a power pack
we're gonna take this one here put it
onto the positive side
of the car and you're gonna take the
other one
put it to the negative side you see it's
already started sparking
this one here if you want to test it
you see it's red but if you push here
just go all the way to the white
that means it's not bad so now
the first thing you need to do you have
a battery
voltage is good i'm going to close the
door for the noise
here is the obd2 place
and also we have
a place where we have to put the key
look here
this is a place where you're gonna put
the key in the slot
as soon as you put it it show there
now we're gonna go to our machine always
keep this machine
charged now i have 11 person charge if
you don't use it put it in the charger
right now i have to stay for one hour to
let this
machine charge which is means that i was
a little bit
busy or i forget it or what they call it
english
procurement destination something like
that okay
now you don't go to diagnosis you go to
emo
hazard light have to be on see
hazard light is on
good now he ask you
like disclaimer you better agree with it
if not you can go
you cannot go to the next accept it be
sure that he is going to be
light up also in this place if it
doesn't light up it's no good so i'm
going to go
you cannot do vin so i'm going to go by
asian car then look for infinity
letter i all these are
our nissan company infiniti no i mean
japan japanese car asian car
when i say asian is taking korean cars
all this now
i want to check automatically do i have
to read the vin number
escape this i gotta go to manual
selection
north america us
infinity fx35 g
infinity g s 35 this one
v6 2006 no
this is g v 37 2008 to 7.
this is a car i will say yes
okay hot function not did i went to
uh i went to another place
this is not the place i supposed to go
to
i supposed to go to immobilizer
so if maybe i shoot something wrong let
me see
let me come back again let me open some
air
i'm gonna open it again sorry for that
anymore accept
i cannot get the win because of no
ignition
so what do you need to do
go by asian car
infinity
let me see what automatic selection what
it's gonna say
yeah automatic selection is not a vein
so hazard on
please eliminate this thermal cluster
before operating
if the ignition is not turning on put
the thermocolossa on
if the ignition connector on please open
and close the driver door
i close it we say okay
now zero percent it may take up two
hundred percent that means at least
two minutes just keep going
i'm gonna pause it 38 percent
stop 40.
this one here it work the same way for
maxima ultima
infinity with this battery slot problem
you see where you have a slot
here where you put the keyboard there
that's where you register it
after you finish then you're gonna put
it in your pocket
to do the other work in our 88 person
please subscribe share and like
you have a question feel free to ask now
i need to do another one i'm going to go
to star 2.
diagnose this one will prepare
the system for you the bcm is not
communicating or you have a fault
because you have a fault it becomes
orange
but if it's if it's like orange it's not
coming
this color is no communication but if
it is like this is fault there's a fault
in it
so this color is like like more not like
red
so that mean is communicating after 57
percent after 100 percent
we have two two-way add add a key
guideline
or all key loss guided guided means it
will tell you step by step
here we have the bcm number you see this
one
one for echo zero f you can take this
one here
convert it to a number i believe
and then that number will tell you what
what you're gonna do
it you're gonna put it in a place but
this guy will do the calculation and you
do the bypass
if you're using dealer tools you must
have another calculator outside
so this is the advantage between the
dealer tools
and the locksmith tools which means a
locksmith will have more advantage and
save your time and money
in some jobs but for some cars if you
don't have the dealer tool you can shut
off the
shut down the whole system so i'm gonna
go all key lost
how many step i have three step get the
pin i'm gonna click
start when i click the start
it says the vehicle why because i need
to maybe sometime you need to do
you have to go through the steering
steering lock release but let's see what
happened
if it's working here okay if it's not
you have to succeed
see all the key we lost
this thing is work i will say okay
if this fell this is the wrong way to go
with this
it's gonna be no communication
nothing is working
turn the ignition off yes
yeah you hear the steering column before
was not turning
you hear the noise you say kick it that
means it's good
insert the key into the slot without
depressing brake pedal
turn the key on so let me see if i turn
the key on i supposed to get
light blinking there five times see key
is on
i don't see any light blinking
but ignition is on so let me see what
you got
maybe you have to take the ignition out
take the key out
turn the ignition off i turn the
ignition off
remove the key okay
insert the smart key press start stop
one time
you say the external clash will
eliminate
and then wait for a max you know like
and automatically you know like it will
maybe sometimes flash five time or
something so let's see
i'm gonna put it back turn the key on
i supposed to get something for last
five time there
yeah you see it's blinking that means
it's gonna take the program
i'm gonna take the key out again the
light will go off
but i'm gonna take it again put it in if
i turn it on this
time the ignition is on but if i take
the key
light will stay on that this program is
done
we'll close it you see it woke
now i'm gonna turn it off now i don't
need to put the key in the slot
just push it here two times the ignition
is on
let me see i gotta push the brake to
start
yes our
car start battery is not charging
alternate is not charging but at least
the car is start
now what i'm gonna do i say yes
everything success success success
and this one here all the car that with
the slot
they are working the same thing so if
you have a mechanic
and you have something like this you can
change the computer by yourself you can
do a lot of diagnosis
you can do diagnosis too i'm gonna
escape
i'm gonna escape here and
the case is close thank you for watching
mobile electronic diagnostic best car
fixes please
subscribe share like let our
channel grow you're going to see this
video
and if you have any question please feel
feel free to ask
and i will do my best to answer thank
you this is muhammad harold natris